like look that's a nice place we just
next to it go out there back out but
then you're gonna get the look at the
nice place now the truth is seven out of
ten murders go completely unsolved in
Detroit so I can just run this Dame over
and they never find me of course I'd
never do it of course the terrible thing
you should never joke about it but I
could we want to go down here is that
too much for risk let's give it a whirl
you're armed right if I think your doors
open there get it
so here we go we wanted to do this
because a lot of people think that
you're selectively editing when you talk
about Detroit or as I've done people
think I've been unfair to the city so in
real time we're going to provide you
with a time lapse and a mileage tab to
just how far going out of downtown the
tour's the area where the hipsters love
to claim the Detroit being saved through
art how far out you have to go to see
how the people of Detroit actually live
we're going to do this going east north
and west so with no edits we're going to
put on a mileage tab you'll see exactly
how far out we get to go and then we'll
stop it and drive through the
neighborhoods and that'll be edited
because otherwise it would be a video
but the drive right now we are on this
is the first one like I said we'll do
several different directions because
Detroit for those you don't know is kind
of like a wheel and the streets are
spokes going out of it right now we're
turning onto gretchy oh i don't know how
you crowns in english i don't know if
you guys say grad yet or what but
gretchie o is the word in french
canadian my dad will beat me up as a
native Detroiter for me getting the name
wrong so that was downtown you can see
it right there it's still not far no
editing nothing up my sleeves except my
arm my teacher fat arm um
and here we go are driving out of
downtown Detroit this is all commercial
so we have yet to pass a residential
area it's important listen you'll see
these areas in airline magazines they'll
say that it's coming back but the
policies haven't changed in Detroit the
politics haven't changed the unions are
still very strong so nothing's changed
policy wise except for feelings people
want to feel good about the city so
let's be accurate how far out do you
have to go in any direction to see how
Detroiters live this is the first
residential area upon which we can cut
in there now I can turn out the back
alley and it's a dead-end wish you want
to avoid here in Detroit kind of a main
drag
I can't turn there all right well the
very first Street unto which we can turn
you know what I'm gonna go Bluff left
here to turn so one way it's really hard
to turn here well we try to turn back
there that was the residential so let's
uh probably would have turned that would
have been what what's the most animated
wait lovin one more line a living muscle
are well but so we've been back there so
let's cut it back by a call a
quarter-mile and turn into the very
first area that we could
the Troy sausage company there you go
this is how everyone lives in Detroit a
mile out of the city it's the Freddie
breakfast I picture this is posted on
Airbnb at negative 44 nights you walk in
they just mugged you we're rejuvenating
it through arts you guys and you know I
don't say this we've talked about this I
don't say these things to crap on
Detroit I say it because it was a once
great city and if people deny the
reality the problems that our economic
political in nature we want to go down
here is that too much of a risk
let's give it a whirl you're armed right
here from one of us armed by the way one
fantastic thing you needn't look for
trash cans so again I don't have the
exact meant cuz now we're driving
zigzagging around so we probably added
up quite a few miles but the amount of
distance we driven out of the
Renaissance Center that area is point
three miles when you're driving out in
breccia gratz yet I don't know how you
English people pronounce it I'm a
disgusting frog and you should be
ashamed to watch my videos
watch your mouth and you know what's
funny this is why the murder rate went
down there's just nobody left to kill
but the justifiable homicide rate will
bring the numbers up on screen I think
went up about 73 percent in one year in
Detroit that means basically you know
self-defense in cases where was ruled
justifiable homicide because there
aren't a lot of people left to kill but
usually when it's prosecuted that's
because someone came forward and was
like I asked a [ __ ] they go yeah
sure you're homicide was justifiable
what are you doing there what do you do
you put a GoPros on your car what are
you doing what did you think would
happen and of course remember
when you see this think Detroit Union
strong that's their slogan they want you
to remember that so when you think this
think Detroit you see all this Union
want you to think of them cheaper just
wonder when you're around here and
people are just hanging out on corners
you're like whoop I'm 28 years old I've
never in my life just hung out on a
corner dude I mean I think it's cuz you
have a lot of living love to do it just
never happened look at this this is a
downtown Detroit again point three miles
it's not like you're going all the way
out here for Brooklyn
like Canarsie you're going out to Coney
Island right this is this is right here
mcdougal and Willis mcdougal and Willis
because I know you're gonna get some how
dare you make fun of my city it's great
we're rejuvenating it with coffee shop
and MacBooks doors following off you
know a lot of hipsters but they move
into about four blocks downtown and in
little gated security you know doorman
buildings and there still has been an
epidemic of hipster muggings and hipster
rapes not hipsters raping hipsters
ripping zippers getting raped assassin
that's impressive surprise we've seen
that one coming Schuyler so like what
like a block like this is actually not
because most what's a band this isn't as
bad at some of the blocks we've seen how
would this rate in Cleveland well I
don't I've never seen this much grass in
Cleveland I'm just like
well that's people didn't believe me I'm
talking about packs of wild dogs I
didn't make it up I mean there's just so
much of the problem with the city you
know why crime can be so bad is when
it's destitute when it's abandoned if
it's really crowded you know you're
going to be a lot safer because there
are some folks who you know gonna see
you get killed and that's just not good
business here you know you can leave
someone in a field for days and they
dissociate the rotting smell to just
Detroit okay so in this course sure KFC
pawnshop liquor store all the
necessities I know I know what people
are going to say I know what they're
going to say lotta lot oh I know what
they're gonna say yes
by the way Detroit important for all of
you hipsters you want to come down here
and talk about how you live amongst the
people and you're saving a city it is
still advisable that you um run the red
lights should you be able to if I were a
kid I would think this is awesome that's
like the world's best tree house you
avoid the needles of course and you the
you know the surgical tubing but it it's
just your canvas I know you're going to
say what is his racist listen we're just
driving to Detroit okay and let's be
honest there's a demographic here that
tends to be a predominantly Asian yes I
was going to say a huge Japanese
community matter of fact some people
have associated their rapid rise in
crime too
to honor suicide because it's so common
in the Japanese community that they say
that might alter the crime statistics
where this isn't where they have the
Dockers Vindhya oh there it is there it
is yes so this is the area just so you
know when you're reading your airline
magazines and all the progressives and
all the people who are lying themselves
in delusional they want to tell you well
there's a really big art theme in
Detroit and have you been down to look
at the name it's like art something our
towel isn't it they called art town sort
of knows it's a haunted house there's an
art town we can find you gave our Indian
village so this is you know this is when
you receive there was an article in it I
don't know it was American Airline
someplace recently when they're really
trying to convince people that Detroit
is coming back well this is what they're
talking about this is probably the
biggest accomplishment that Detroit has
had beyond a few Coffee Roasters in the
last few years
fire gotta what is that did they crucify
that teddy bear is he wearing the wrong
gang colors Teddy I don't even know what
gang purple is but you should have
stayed neutral or the wrong bandana that
he wore the wrong bandana the ticket
yard sale I never closed by the way will
bring up a picture last time we were
here there was a meth lab fire right
here I don't know if we can find that
building again but right here as a
matter of fact this is not
Heidelberg project I'd only one it said
this is not Heidelberg project it said
Heisenberg one thing I will say though
about Detroit um beautiful wildlife
afterthought Detroit was in trouble
look at that I got a sundress on a
willow
it's just what it's just what the doctor
ordered
oh my god the city's bankrupt we have
the highest murder rate in the country
it's not even close yes but have you
seen the pantsuit on the maple tree they
find so funny - it's a muumuu they
weren't even willing to put in the
effort to put up a nice dress
on a tree some hipster literally scraped
the bottom of their donation bin and
instead of donating these clothes they
said you know what I'm going to ease my
white guilt by pinning this to an elm
tree and then tell everyone that I've
saved the city and the truth is seven
out of ten murders go completely
unsolved in Detroit so I could just run
this game over and they'd never find me
of course I'd never do it of course it's
a terrible thing you should never joke
about it but I could this is the problem
is you have these people who go out
there and they lie these hipsters and
people who want to make you think
something about Detroit because I take
this false pride in a city you were
really you know it's like a child
Detroit as a child that needs to be
spanked it's a child that needs to be
disciplined and if you just say no my
kids the best kid you're like that
parent at the PTA going my kids the best
kid they're gonna actually your kid is
part of a gang in he's shooting and
raping other kids in class when he
should be playing with crayons no no
that doesn't sound like little little
Detroit well it is Detroit why don't you
discipline it why don't you no no no I'm
pretty sure we're gonna I'm pretty sure
we're doing is working that's the issue
you don't you don't point out the
inherent um the systematic
just proliferation of you don't point it
out because you're trying to bad-mouth a
city you pointed out because you're
trying to save it right the first step
toward fixing a problem is acknowledging
that you have one okay so here we go
right from here Detroit Tiger Stadium
okay Tiger Stadium we'll set out our
mileage tab let's see how long before we
get out of you can't get more touristy
than Tiger Stadium how long until we get
to the area that hipsters deployed oh
the hockey town cafe it's a lot of fun I
spent a lot of time there and what you
gonna work on oh my god it's almost
sundown we have to get back to Grosse
Pointe but I got my goatee so I'm pretty
sure the hood path there's a one moment
with every father and son here is like
Simba everything he touches is our kids
our Keita
all right so you have the mileage
sticker going do you do yeah which is
actually eight point one eight okay from
Tigers team this is actually to be fair
there are some really nice apartments
here because you do have Wayne State and
you can still see you know all here and
over all these buildings here are
abandoned completely and this is still
downtown but there are some legitimately
nice apartments here so gated yeah I
mean you know doormen not New Mexican a
lot of Japanese implement talked about
that okay how far are we out now we're
point four two point four two so the
north side is a nicer side we got a
little bit further out but it's time to
turn and do the real neighborhoods and
here we go point eight okay so yeah you
can stop the ticker now 0.8 or 0.5 0.5
0.5 I was I don't know Wi-Fi playing
okay think it's worse
no no no there is a healthy piece of
bark and texture here's the I mean
here's the problem people going to get
mad and trashing a city how many home
luma see it can you just consider
historic until you go away hold on a
second
it's not historic so much as this city's
history
okay a historic myth Bob they're in a
historic I'd a long made the front cover
of all the papers it's like I was at AA
try the clue when he was a real estate
agent Simpsons thing that's nice is
dilapidated its rustic so you can still
see Tiger Stadium there 21 zoom in for
them yep so there you go you get some
scope as to how far out you are and then
rotate around here
you have to see the good
if you only look for the dilapidated
crack houses and dead bodies you'll only
find dilapidated crack houses and their
bodies if you look for the positive look
look that's a nice place
I mean it's next to it they'll operator
crack outs but then you're gonna get to
look at the nice place so again this
would be the nicest air this is actually
pretty nice to be fair now in any of the
city which is the nicest area probably
not but there you go you got a better
friend house or sorority house I know
either way someone's getting sexually
accosted but this is again this is the
nicest area I would probably say that
we've seen so I didn't prepare me
because you could right now across
people are this mis'able superiors well
you could set up you know you could
build a life for your family here if
your family was crack [ __ ] Detroit
behavior all the time
oh well then even on a nice Club you
probably want to live on that block
what's crazy though I mean this is like
they're really nice cuz it's Wayne State
and you got that Whole Foods we're a
block from just you know an entire
Street of dilapidated buildings that the
ice cream truck we're right there no no
that was a rapist fan you know they're
really confusing they're very similar
and that's the problem with
gentrification of Detroit you can no
longer tell the rapist fans from the ice
cream trucks that's really problem for
children these this problem for children
some would say it's almost deliberate
so here you go this is the right there
Thaddeus right behind us can't report it
that's the statue downtown now we're
heading out west on Michigan which is
one of the main streets here so I would
expect we'll get a little bit further
outside of downtown again you have to
ignore you know these kinds of buildings
and all the stuff that's abandoned and
of course fire hazards this is kind of a
new hip area so oh no what
let's turn right there let me move back
around so for context this is going out
West Michigan Avenue going into a
neighborhood Corktown there's downtown
you're about 0.2 miles from downtown
would you say you get to the apartments
right next to this you know you don't
know what the problem is you don't know
what's living in that you have no idea
what's in there
just wondering if I can yeah there we go
okay second well here you go
here's more you just you know downtown
again for context just so people aren't
saying where you drove 10 miles out out
we're driving alongside downtown behind
these buildings our downtown is downtown
and there's the old Grand Central
Station that is of course completely
abandoned and this is the really kind of
cool hip area here without flexors
hangout so you've got to like slows
barbecue White Castle is always pretty
popular this is a there slows right
there they're you know they're slow so
like I said put the mileage tab back on
the first place we could have turned and
now let's put another mileage tab here
but we'll go into another neighborhood
that we can find these places look nice
I mean it's Lowe's is decent barbecue
place you know right across from it you
got this building - CPA building which
is you know
I mean do you think the bars were put up
on that building before it was abandoned
like you think there was a step but you
know what we're gonna stick or we're
gonna stick it out let's put up the bars
and then they just go in and forget
about it or do you think they abandoned
it and we're like you know what let's at
least give this building the respect of
putting up the bars on the nice could
have painted a hurt
somewhat recently someone would be on it
I can't turn left actually that's a lot
better than when I came here four or
five years ago in a Detroit thing I
guess they've been doing a restoration
project they're still finding that
bodies oh yeah you know you still find
dead elbows in the elevator chef but you
know it's not without its enough nothing
is without its challenges if you just
look for the dead elbows in the elevator
shaft you're only going to see dead
hobos in the elevator shaft and you're
not going to see the Dockers pins to the
tree next to the elevator shaft so here
we go this is right around the Grand
Central area and right across from that
kinda I guess you'd call them struggling
on don't drive
okay let's cross to a lot good just
sleeping right in the middle the Rose
Bowl little guy nine Scrolls of anything
although for a year you know there you
go so from right here there's no that's
it
so this is the Grand Central um a credit
where it's due you know it's not I mean
listen not functional and it you know
they put up a couple plates of glass so
this is kind of what so emblematic of
Detroit right the front of Grand Central
I guess that it is definitely better
than five years ago but there's the
front that they have a few window panes
and now here is the back so again when
you're just outside of downtown there's
the overpass here's the back of Grand
Central
this week we shot all this five years
ago you can see it in the if we didn't
directly comment comment on it you can
see it in the montages horrible position
please get theft watching moves they
look so getting up words they sound
you're discreet
danger
well I think your doors open there yeah
this movie it's open
so it looks like gay Jarrod found a
union and I'm doing this on my own here
but if you liked the video subscribe or
click one of the other videos if I can
get them playing in the box there Jared
of the contract I'm pretty sure I can
obligate them to fulfill it